hey everybody so we're actually done uh
filming for the day
but i'm back in the studio because um i
need to get ahead of something that that
may be happening which is
um unfortunate and i
think it's important to to get something
on the record about it before it happens
in case it's going to
many of you saw the segment that i did
on tuesday when we got back from the
memorial day holiday
uh talking about an incident i had over
the weekend
where at a restaurant someone yelled a
jew zionist imperialist to me as i was
walking out of a
of an outdoor seating area at a
restaurant and
um i got a lot of messages of support
and response and
i also got some anti-semitic messages in
response to my telling of that story
basically par for the course
this segment has started to make the
rounds
in some right-wing circles and today i
heard from
a right-wing public figure who's very
well connected
who told me in relatively uncertain
terms
that there are some high-profile people
on the right
i don't know who this is supposed to be
i i have no idea
just some high-profile people on the
right people who i've talked about on my
program before
who are going to be um publicly
supporting me against this left-wing
anti-semitism that i experienced over
the weekend
i do believe that that's what it was i
want to be really clear that
anti-semitic messages being sent to me
are something that's been going on as
long as i've been doing this show
the vast majority are from the right but
i've not shied away from saying that
some of it is from the left
but the vast majority of anti-semitism
that i get is from the right
and what this individual said is
that the people who are going to come
out
in support of me are the types of people
whose support
could turn the left against me in other
words
and again i don't know who these people
supposedly are but that these are the
folks who if if
the left sees they are supporting me uh
as the victim of this anti-semitic
semitic incident
um that my you know my left wing core
audience is going to be furious and
they're going to abandon me etc
i don't think that's going to happen
because my audience knows me
uh but i do want to get ahead of this
because if this happens
and the person bringing this to me may
be mistaken or they may not be telling
the truth i don't know yet but the
reason i want to get out ahead of it is
that if this happens
this is not support i'm looking for
and it is not a genuine attempt to deal
with the issue of anti-semitism
which exists so significantly on the
right it is a
naked brazen and cynical attempt
to weaponize one story that i told you
about my experience
against the left to say that the left is
somehow uniquely anti-semitic i'll be
the first to say i'm repeating it for
clarity
i've called out anti-semitism on the
left and i've called it out on the right
most of what i get is is from the right
but occasionally it's from the left
so whoever supports me
in the coming hours or days it changes
nothing about my experience it changes
nothing about
my political affiliation it changes
nothing about
the stories i've been telling you guys
for more than a decade on this program
at this point in time now
why am i not just showing you the
communications i received and telling
you who it is
because if i did i'd be a hypocrite some
of you may remember that when
tim poole published some of the private
conversations
i thought they were private that he and
i had about
you know online marketing and stuff um
we how do i want to say this those were
not conversations i believed were for
for publication and if i have what i
believe to be a private conversation
with someone
i'm not going to then publish that and
name that person and show you
screenshots because it just doesn't seem
right so i'm not going to do it now
either because then
i'd be a hypocrite and that's the reason
why at some point in the future we'll
see how this all develops
uh maybe that's something that i will
talk about but the point here
is i don't know where this might be i
don't know if this is going to be
on a prominent right-wing website on a
prominent right-wing radio show
television show a prominent right
winger's twitter account i don't know
what may be coming
but the point here is there may be a
very cynical attempt to take that
anecdote that i told
um and to use it to attack the left and
um i want to be sure that everybody
knows that
i am we are anticipating this we are
watching for this
and i am not seeking the support
of any prominent right wingers on this
issue
uh and i would take their support far
more seriously if it came
if they seemed committed to rooting out
right-wing anti-semitism rather than
just trying to make a political
statement okay so that
i'm trying to be as least cryptic as i
can this is all the information i have
at this point in time uh
if this ends up being nothing i will
actually
be fine and then we won't hear about it
anymore if this ends up being something
i'm guessing you will hear about it and
then we'll discuss and analyze
going forward from that point in time